Okay. What I'm planning to do today
is to spend half an hour or less,
I'm just telling you, but little bit
about what a new theory might be,
a what I call the leverage cycle.
And then to spend the rest of the time
maybe answering questions about the
course that you might have.
I could if he wanted to devote the
whole time to what the new theory is.
But why don't I at least pause after half
an hour and see if you have questions.
So,
um,
what is the saying that's been missing
from the entire course and has been
missing from economic theory,
I think almost entirely
for all these years. Uh,
and certainly missing from all the
textbooks that you might have looked at
during the course of the semester.
And you remember there were list of 20
bucks or something you could have read.
And that's the idea of collateral.
And it's the idea that in order to
guarantee that you're going to keep your
promise,
you have to put up collateral and
people just don't trust in everyone else
keeping their promise. They
want collateral. So if you
put that into the model, uh,
what sorts of things might be different?
So I want to just work out an example
so you can see how they might change.
I want to talk about an example that's
going to illustrate how you might,
what happened in our crisis.
And I guess it's a little
interesting that I wrote this in.
I presented this in 2000 at a world
congress and it finally got published in
2003 so this was long
before the crisis. Um, uh,
now as I said, there'd been other
smaller crises before in 1998,
maybe [inaudible] 94,
maybe 87, certainly 98.
And of course I was thinking about these
previous crises when I built this model,
but not many other people thought much
of those other crises. And as it happens,
this last one that we're still at the
bottom of are a little past the bottom of,
I think it's very similar to the ones
we had before. Um, but just much bigger.
So here's my simple version of it.
I'm going to give two models,
a very simple one with two periods.
And a slightly more complicated
one with three periods.
And of course all the interesting
things happen in a three period case.
But just to make it simple to understand,
I'm starting with the simpler ones.
So suppose that there's a security,
which I'm going to call,
why that everybody holds.
Why is there no shark?
Gosh,
I taught the class in here.
I just finished lecturing
in here with a whole bock.
Oh, here, this whole box of jock. Okay.
So suppose that there's a security why
that I'm going to think of as a mortgage
security or you could think of it as
a house or you could think of it as a,
an oil well that has uncertain
output and the next period,
and then there's going to be
something like gold that I'll call x.
So this might be like gold and this
might be like a mortgage security
or like an oil. Well, uh, where are,
you might think of it as a house,
but I'll think of a mortgage security,
an oil well,
it's something that pays an
uncertain outcome in the future.
And this is something that's very
stable. And you know, exactly,
you've got gold this period.
If you just save it,
you'll have the same gold next period.
So now people are going to differ
according to how optimistic or pessimistic
they are. That's my idea of
not everybody's the same.
So I imagine that there are
two possibilities next period.
Either the why the oil well produce.
It's a Goldwell really.
It could produce two pieces of
gold or it could produce point,
I mean one piece of gold or it could
produce 0.2 20% of a piece of gold.
So everybody begins with one oil,
well,
one Morgan security and one piece of gold.
So they can,
they can consume the gold or they can,
you know,
make it a filling for their teeth.
Or they could wait next period
and then they'd have it, uh,
in either state next period because it's
perfectly durable. Or they could, uh,
use the gold to buy more oil wells,
each of which might pay off one or 0.2.
So that's it. Now people care
about the consumption of gold.
The only reason they get the oil,
well as Fisher as we've
assumed all through the class,
the only reason to get the oil well is
that it might produce gold for your next
period. Gushing oil, money, gold.
It might gush some gold for you next
period. So people care about consumption,
how much gold they eat here times the
probability that they're going to be up
here at times,
how much they here plus the probability
that they're going to come down here at
times, how much they'd
hear, in other words,
their risk neutral with no discounting
and they just multiply consumption here
and here by the probabilities and add
the consumptions and then added to the
consumption here.
That's what everybody's got the same
utility but with one difference.
H is the probability agent
h attaches to going up.
So I think of these people
as a continuum of buyers.
Now instead of two buyers
like we've always, yeah,
sad or three buyers or even one buyer.
I've got a continuum and they are
different because some are more optimistic
than others.
Now this is stuff that we haven't
really paid much attention to before.
So these optimists are the people who
have h very close to one and you know,
lots of other people have ages in the
middle and there's some people who think h
zero that's the way they differ.
So of course the very most optimistic
person thinks the oil well is worth one
piece of gold. He doesn't discount and
he thinks he's going to get one for sure.
So He'd be paid willing to pay one for it.
Here the most pessimistic person thinks
the oil well is only worth 0.2 and let's
say she'd only be willing
to pay 0.2 for it here.
Okay,
so what's the price of oil
wells going to be? Well,
if we just had our, yeah, [inaudible]
old model or one period model,
we would see the people with the high
age would sell their gold to buy more oil
wells because they thought
it would be valuable.
And the people with the low H's thinking
the oil wells weren't worth much,
would sell them to the high h people
to get more gold in the present.
That's basically what would happen.
Okay.
And you'd get some dividing line or
the people above a would be buying oil
wells,
spending all their money and the people
below a would be selling oil wells and
getting more money.
So for example,
if a was 0.69 which is what it's
going to turn out to be, uh,
Mister Aa. How, what does he
think the value of an oil well is?
He thinks it's 0.69 times one plus 0.31
times 0.2 which is 0.06 so 0.69 plus 0.0
6.75 okay,
so mister 69 things,
the oil wells worth about 75 and so if
the price everyone above him and thinks
it's worth more than 75 so if the price
were worth 75 everyone above would want
to buy and everyone below would say,
well it's not worth 0.75 so I'll sell it.
And since the risk neutral, you
know, they don't have their,
their valuation is independent
of how much of it they have.
So these people below would want to sell
everything and these people above would
want to buy everything.
So that's nothing different from what
we've done from the very beginning except
that maybe the one differences,
people would go to the
extreme, they would end up,
these guys would spend all their money
buying oil wells because every time they
bought an oil well at a price of 0.75
this guy for example is sure it's worth
one. The more he buys, the better he is.
So he spent all his money in oil wells
and these guys would sell all their oil
wells. But other than that it's
very similar to what we've done.
So what's the difference going to be?
The difference is just one thing.
Where do I divide this dividing
line? Ay well it, you know,
can these guys up here afford
to buy all these oil wells?
Well the answer is so far it doesn't
look like that's possible because if the
dividing line is,
is way up here,
these guys appear don't have enough
money to buy all the oil wells down here.
After all,
they only have one piece of gold a piece.
And if the oil costs 75 they
can each by one and the third.
If you multiply that by one and a third,
you're never going to buy all
these oil wells down here.
So this seems like it's
too high for a to B.
So the new twist is
maybe the guys up here
who want the oil wells,
who are so sure they're going to do well,
maybe they can borrow money
to buy the oil wells. Okay.
So they can make a promise
to pay money in the future,
maybe 0.5 and 0.5 in the future,
say and then sell those promises
and uh, you know, borrow money,
in other words,
promising in the future and then use
that money to buy more oil wells.
So that's what people do in the market.
Any hedge fund,
the three definitions of a hedge fund,
the three defining
characteristics of a hedge fund,
I think I might've said ones are a,
that they hedge.
So unlike other money managers,
they're always trying to hedge.
And we talked about what
hedging is and many,
many more managers are doing that
than ever before. So that's not,
so it's different from 50% of the people,
but not from the hedge funds or 5%.
And the other 45% are also hedgings.
That's not so different.
The second thing they do is they
borrow money to make their investments.
A lot of these other managers
aren't allowed to borrow. They just,
they may not be allowed to hedge either.
Those are called long only managers.
They can't hedge. Some of them
can't borrow hedge funds. Borough,
I mean hedge and borrow. And then hedge
funds charge high fees. That's the third,
uh, defining characteristic.
But anyway, so they borrowed.
So a lot of these p and in the economy,
I told you last time a huge number of
people borrowed a huge amount of money.
So borrowing is obviously very important.
So how much are they going to be able
to borrow? I mean, this guy, number one,
he'd like to borrow as much as he could.
Every time he borrows money,
he's sure that he's going to be up here.
So every time he borrows a dollar,
he gets to make an investment that he
sure is going to be a great investment and
he's planning on paying everything back
because you know he sure he's going to
go up here. So He's going to
be incredibly rich. So He's,
he's going to pay back what he borrows,
but he's going to get my at such a profit.
He's going to make a fortune.
So if people could borrow however much
they wanted to and promise to pay back,
this guy would borrow
everything, Mr One. I mean,
we'd borrow everything and imagine
he was going to get up here for sure.
And I imagine he was going to keep his
promise for sure and he'd bid the price
up almost to one.
Okay,
but now who's going to lend to them and
how much will they actually lend to them?
Well, in our old world, we didn't
worry about who was gonna land.
Everybody assumed they're going
to get paid back. But in reality,
people don't assume they're
going to get paid back.
The lenders are going to say
to themselves, wait a minute,
if this guy promises us
to pay us a 0.5 and 0.5,
um, maybe he'll be very rich over
here and we'll be able to pay us back.
But you know, I'm not sure he's
going to be so rich here. I mean,
what is it that he had?
I don't even know what he has.
How do I know what the borrower is
going to actually have in the states?
I don't want to look into his personal
bank account and find out everything
about him.
And you know,
that's the way banks who lend sometimes
do that and they go to a lot of effort
to check. You know, how
reliable a borrower you are,
but people in general, but most
of the lenders don't, you know,
you don't want to do that.
That was the idea of securitization.
We don't have to have so much careful
looking into the personal finances.
So everybody much simpler
is to use the asset.
Why is collateral? So if, why is
collateral? What does that mean?
When you lend a dollar to a borrower,
the borrower just doesn't borrow the book.
The dollar promising to pave something
back in the future. The borrower says,
if I don't pay you back,
you can take the asset.
So the question is for each
unit of the asset, why?
How much can you borrow when you
have the asset as collateral?
That's the question of leverage.
So if you take the value of y
divided by the, uh, the,
the cash down, okay, so the,
so let's do two numbers.
So the borrowed
all is burrowed using Y as collateral
that divided by the value of y.
That's what we call the loan to value
LTV, loan to value, okay?
Another way of saying
that is the borrowed.
If you take why dollar y
minus dollars borrowed,
okay? That all right, well, Trey,
the denominator dollars bar,
dollar y minus dollars borrowed,
okay?
And here you put value of y.
So just dollar Y my boards.
Okay,
the dollar of y minus the dollar borrower,
that's the cash you had to put down.
So that's the dollar of y
divided by the cash down.
They,
that's what's called leverage.
Okay.
So, and it's obviously the same thing as
loan to value because you just sort of
invert the number and do a subtraction.
You get leverage.
So if you knew the loan devalue
nor the leverage and vice versa,
they're the same thing.
So what should the loan devalue be?
And so as I said in the,
uh,
in historically what's happened over the
last 10 years for housing is you had to
put 14% down.
The leverage was seven for buying houses,
non non, uh, agency houses,
non-prime houses starting in 2000.
And then it went to 33 or 35 to one
because you put down less than 3% the in a
2006. So this leverage shot up
and then it suddenly collapsed,
you had to put 25% down. Okay,
so leverage fell to four.
So that I'm going to explain has a big
effect on what the House on the price of
housing and the price of mortgage
securities. So what should leverage me?
How can supply and demand
determine what leverage is?
So it seems like you've got
to clear all these markets.
You've got to figure out how does the Y,
sorry, how does the, why market clear?
How does the gold market clear?
Um,
and then on top of that you
have to figure out leverage.
It seems like it's a lot of
complicated things to figure out.
And I think economist just thought,
wow, there's so much going on, you know,
we might as well,
and people really Gilani generally
keeping their promises anyway.
Let's ignore the fact that you have
to have all this collateral. Well,
I think the collateral is the
heart of the problem in finance.
So how would it work in this
uh, model? So are you with me?
But what the where, where
we're going? Okay. So
you have to conceptually figure
out how to think about the problem.
So that was a, so how, in other words,
conceptually the question is
how can supply equals demand,
which sounds like one equation.
How can that determine leverage?
Yeah.
Well, the interest rate supply
equals demand for loans.
Okay.
How can that determine the interest rate?
And the leverage.
Okay.
It seems like you have one equation and
how can you determine two things with
one equation? Well, the
answer is that you can do it.
Okay.
And so we just soaked.
But first we need a conceptual
framework to think about it.
So it seems like a contradiction,
almost a mathematical contradiction.
So it must be that the problem is
ill posed and so I claim it is.
So what you really should be thinking is
that there's not just one interest rate
and one leverage.
You should be thinking that there's
the Collat, there's the promise.
Okay.
And then there's the collateral and
those things taken together. Define,
define the contract.
So let's say the promises point to 0.2
and the collateral is one unit of y.
Okay.
Going to have x 0.2 of x.
So you're promising to units of gold in
the future and you've got one unit of
why is your collateral.
So that implies a delivery
of
0.2 and point to why is that?
Because in the good state at the top,
the collateral is worth one.
So if you've made the promise and
the lender can seize your collateral,
if you don't pay,
you're getting either pay point to where
he's going to seize the collateral.
And so you're gonna pay point too.
Maybe you'll sell some of the
collateral to pay point too.
And if the promises a 0.2 down here,
the same thing,
either he's going to seize the collateral,
the lender will seize the collateral,
you'll sell it and keep your promise.
In either case,
it'll live are point to point to and
it's going to sell for some price.
Okay.
And the price is actually going to be one.
So the interest rate effectively zero,
why is that?
Well,
because at time zero over here,
no one discounts the future gold at the
beginning is worth exact to everybody.
I unit of gold at the beginnings of the
same as the unit of gold at the end,
you know, in both states, cause everyone's
probabilities at up to one, you know,
age plus one minus h is one.
So you might as well consume at the
beginning or for sure at the end.
So since there's a lot of
gold sloshing around here,
they're always lenders willing to lend
at a 0% interest and they're getting
their money back for sure.
So it'll turn out that the interest rate
on this kind of loan, which is riskless,
is going to be zero because
no one's discounting and
they're getting their money
for sure.
But what if you promise 0.3 and 0.3
yeah,
with one unit of y as collateral.
Hey,
then what would the delivery
be in that case? Well,
the delivery wouldn't be 0.3 0.3 because
the only thing protecting the promise
is the collateral we'll delivery
would be 0.3 and point to,
right,
because in the upstate your collateral
is worth one and so you would be forced
to pay the 0.3 in the downstate.
You would do what a lot of homeowners
are doing now and say, okay,
I owe you so much money.
You know,
my loan devalues 150% the value of
my house has gone down to two thirds.
The loan is 140 or 50% of the
value of my house. I mean,
I'd be crazy to pay you 150%. Um,
you know, I don't effectively,
I don't own my house. I owe so much more
than my house than a the house is worth.
I can't give it to my children.
I can't do anything with the house anyway.
Why should I just pay such a
huge amount of money? You know,
I might as well just give up the house.
They walk away from the house
and the lender gets point too.
So 0.3 0.2 would be the delivery.
And of course if it was 0.4 and 0.4,
it would also be 0.4 and 0.2.
Okay.
Now if you made this
promise of 0.3 and 0.3,
you'd be delivering something
more than 0.2 at the top.
So the price,
of course we'd be more than 0.3.
So the price might be priced at the 0.3
promise will turn out to be something.
Okay?
Like 0.2, six one say. Okay,
it might be 0.261 let's just say 0.261.
Okay.
So effectively you're borrowing 0.261
you're delivering 0.3 this is the 0.3 this
is up here.
Pie Point three 0.261 sub 0.3 okay?
So effectively what your
interest rate is in the state,
when you can pay back at the top,
your interest rate is like
is a 0.39 over 0.261 it's uh,
like 14% or 15% actually it's a 15% okay,
so 0.3 of or 0.61261 is a
so 0.3 over 0.261 is 1.15.
So this over here means 15% interest.
Okay?
So you've effectively,
because they know you're going
to default and one of the states,
you have to pay much more than
you borrowed in the good state.
So effectively you're
promising a 15% interest.
You're promising it and all the
states you're only delivering, you're,
you're not only delivering a portion
of what you promise in the bad state.
All right. So what's my
point? My point is that the,
the apparent contradiction supply
equals demand. Determining one.
Both interest in leverage
is no contradiction at all
because actually we've got
many supply equals demand equations.
There are many different loans
depending on what the collateral,
the ratio of the collateral
to the promise. Okay.
There are many different loans in each
of themselves for a different price.
So we've got many different things.
We're determining many
interest rates determined by,
but one supply equals demand
equation for each one.
So every supply equals demand
equation produces one price.
There's no contradiction.
However,
that's still raised leaves
us with the question,
which of these many contracts
are going to be traded?
Can we say that the economy as a whole
has a single rate of a single leverage
and they're, the surprise is, and this is
the end of the first part of the model,
the surprise is yes,
we can only this one
is going to get traded.
Hmm.
So everybody in the economy,
no matter how optimistic you
are or how pessimistic you are,
even though you have the available chance
to make a bigger promise, of course,
having to promise a bigger
interest rate, even though, sorry,
there's the interest rate. Even though
everyone has available that opportunity,
they won't avail themselves of that.
Everybody will trade on this promise.
So how could that be? And by the
way, before we answer that question,
let's just see that if everyone used
this promise that in fact the price we
talked about before would,
would prevail. Okay?
So why is this 0.69 that a
should be a little lower?
It doesn't look like 0.69 looks
a little too high. But anyway,
it's supposed to be 69% of the way up. Why
is that the right price? Well, how much,
how much could these guys buy?
Well,
the top 31% okay there.
What can they do?
They've got 0.31 cigarettes,
okay, so I'll write it over here. They've
got 0.31 cigarette's between them,
the top 31% of the buyers,
right?
So we've got 31% here and
69% of the people down here,
okay?
And here's a equals 0.69 so these guys
have three one cigarette's between them.
Now if they promise every
time they buy an oil,
well they promised 0.2 units.
Okay, there's a container.
Every one of them, they're going to buy
all the oil wells and the whole economy.
So however many people there are here,
let's call it massive one,
maybe it's a million people,
massive one, they're going to buy,
they're going to borrow 0.2.
Okay?
So this is their own gold.
And this is borrowed goal.
Did I say cigarettes? Yes, I
met. Yeah. It's another example
of a gold, I meant gold.
So you can think of gold,
consume it now or consume it later.
Cigarettes you can consume
now or consume later.
You have all these identity things in
my head of what I could have interpreted
it. So yeah, I mean gold. So you
can consume the goal. Thank you.
The gold now or the gold
later. Okay, so you've owned,
each of these guys owns a unit of gold.
So 31% of the population has a
unit of gold. So you've got 0.3,
one total units of gold.
They end up buying all the oil wells.
And so that's uh,
uh,
how much can they borrow on all
the oil wells using as collateral?
So the oil wells,
they started with they burrow using those
as collateral and the oil wells that
they buy, they also use as collateral.
So they've got all the oil wells,
they're making the point to point to
promise. Okay. But it has a price of one,
there's no interest,
it's interest rate is zero.
So they're borrowing 0.2 so the total
amount of gold that they have at their
disposal is 0.31 plus point to and how
many oil wells do they have to buy?
Point six 69% of the oils 0.69 and if you
take 31 and 20 that's 51 over 69 which
is about 0.75 which is
exactly what I said,
the prices that's going to make this guy
Mr 69 exactly in different to buying or
selling.
So all the people up here are going to
say at the price of 0.75 it really is a
good deal.
I want to buy and borrow as much as I can.
People down here are all going to want
to sell the people up here with the money
they started with plus what they can
borrow are going to be able to indeed by
all these oil wells at a price of
0.75 that's what we just found.
And that's why that's the equilibrium.
Did that go too fast or
okay?
Almost too fast? Yeah. Question.
I was just wondering
why is that?
Oh okay. Because you're going
to get the money for sure.
So how much money is being
lent basically point to,
so there's a huge number
of guys down here.
They're total amount
of gold is 0.69 right?
They've got 69 there's one giant because
of one unit of gold and the whole
economy,
they own 69% of the gold and they're
only lending in total point too.
So there's lots of extra goal that
they have that they're lending.
So in the interest,
you know,
they don't care whether they get gold
now or gold later cause there's no
discounting and they're getting
the money back for sure.
So competition between these lenders is
going to drive the interest rate all the
way to zero.
If the interest rate were positive,
they'd all want to rush in
and lend because then they're
going to get more gold
out at the end than they had at
the beginning and there and there.
There's not discounting.
So the,
the competition among lenders will
drive the interest rate down to zero and
they're guaranteed to get paid back
because the, the collaterals big enough.
You had a question.
Oh and I said the price is one. Yes,
the price per unit is 0.2. Yeah,
that's horrible.
Thank you.
The prices point to exactly the price
is 0.2 for the promise of point to point
to it's price of one per unit promise
the prices point to exactly. Gosh,
we're in a terrible mistake. Thank
you very much. It's point to exactly.
And that's why these guys,
they are able to uh,
so there the prices points.
So I just do it point to they're all,
they're promising 0.2 and the
price per unit promise. He,
so this price was, yeah, it's prices
point too. Okay. So there for every,
okay, so it per unit promised there
their prices. One in other words.
So they're promising 0.2 and
per unit promise the prices one.
So the price of the whole promises
point to exactly. So it's just that,
so that was, that was, okay.
So the price is point to the pro using
the whole of the economy's worth of oil
wells is collateral.
You can promise 20% of all the
gold and then you're gonna get,
you'll be able to borrow
doing that the same amount,
20% of all the gold because
the interest rates zero.
Yes.
Okay.
So that's why this total amount of
gold that they can get their hands on.
Some people call it liquidity,
all this stuff,
they can get their hands on capital.
They take all that and they
buy all the oil wells they can.
This is how many are being sold and
that's therefore what the price is.
The ratio 51 to 69 is almost exactly
0.75 so I'm rounding off a little bit.
Okay.
And that's why Mr Aa of
0.69 is indifferent at this
price to buying or selling.
The guys above him all want to buy.
This is how much money they can get their
hands on and therefore what they can
spend. All these guys want to
sell. That's what they're selling.
That's why this justifies the price and
these guys are the ones lending to these
guys.
The pessimists have nothing to do but
Latin because they don't want to buy the
acid.
Yeah.
Okay.
Does this make sense?
I'm just going to repeat the same thing
with a three period model where it gets
more exciting, but the logic of this is
critical. So are is everyone with me?
Okay. Now there's one thing I left out in
this one period, model two period model,
which is what about the 0.3 0.3 promise?
You know the optimist?
He said, let's add h equals one
take that guy, he says himself,
I can't lose.
Why should I?
Why should I be satisfied?
Why should I be satisfied
with only promising 0.2 0.2
why don't I make a bigger
promise like 0.3 0.3 okay
with my bigger promise,
I get more money today.
And with that extra money today I can
use it and buy an oil well and uh,
you know,
I'm going to make a profit of 33%.
My 0.75 is going to take
turn into one for sure.
So why isn't that just a
brilliant thing for me to do?
You know? So why should I be satisfied?
The more oil wells I get my hands on,
the better I seem to do.
So why is he not making the
0.3 0.3 promise? Well, if so,
it sounds like he ought to,
but if you think about it one more minute,
you'll realize that he shouldn't.
And why is that?
Because he could promise 0.2 0.2.
So if he makes the 0.3 0.3 promise,
of course he has to give up the point to
point to promise because the oil, well,
he used as collateral
for the 0.3 0.3 promise.
He no longer has available for
the point to point to promise.
So the question isn't, you know,
should he do a 0.3 0.3 promise?
Well if that was the only thing he
could do, of course he wouldn't do that.
So of course it looks profitable but he's
already got a great profit opportunity.
The question is, is it a better profit
opportunity? And the answer is no.
Why is that?
Because he's still delivering 0.2 down
here when he makes the 0.3 0.3 promise.
But when he makes the 0.3 0.3 promise,
he delivers more at the top,
namely 0.3 but that's the state
he sure he is going to happen.
So compared to the point
to point to promise,
he's giving away more money just in the
state that he thinks is going to occur.
That's very expensive for him. That's
a horrible thing for him to have to do.
And who's lending him the money? It's
the guy down here and the guy down here,
that's the pessimists. He's, he doesn't
think that top states going to occur.
So he's only willing to pay extra
money at the beginning. You know,
he's not willing to pay very much extra
money at the beginning because he's
going to get stuff in a state. He doesn't
think it's going to happen. So anyway,
I don't have time to work it all out.
But if you think it through,
you'll realize that nobody wants to do
this trade because the guys at the top
who seem to have the greatest advantage
and doing burrowing more when they
borrow more in this way,
where they're defaulting,
they're actually paying more only in the
state that they think is going to occur.
And the people doing the lending or
getting money only in the state they think
won't occur.
So both of them think it's a worse
arrangement than the original 0.2 0.2
arrangement.
And so they'll,
even though there's a price and
it's available to be traded,
nobody will want to trade it.
Okay.
So the market does indeed
pick out a single leverage.
And what is the leverage?
The leverage as we calculated from
this is the price of the asset,
which is 0.75 divided by the cash down,
which is 0.55 because you could borrow
a point too and that's, you know,
1.4 or something,
I don't know exactly,
but let's say 1.38 leverage
1.35 is the leverage. Okay. So
it's not that high. The leverage.
Yeah.
Okay. And the principle is that we just
discovered when you have this kind of
Heterogeneity,
different kinds of heterogeneity
produce different amounts of leverage,
and I'm not going to be able to talk about
that, but with this kind of leverage,
the promise will always be the
maximum for which there's no default.
Hey, that's how much borrowing is going
to happen in the markets going to allow.
So what market do we always see
that happening in the Ypo market?
It's a one day market.
Uh,
overnight you put up a
security as collateral and
you could borrow money on it
and there's almost never any
default on those markets.
Even in the tremendous crisis,
we just had almost zero defaults in
the repo markets. Mortgage markets,
there were default,
but they're,
the heterogeneity isn't
just how optimistic you are.
It's whether you like to
live in the house or not.
So it's a different case which I
won't have time to cover. Okay,
so this is part one. We're just going
to say the same thing in part two.
I'm going slower than I thought.
But anyway,
the last model is going to be parked too.
So any questions about that?
This first part?
Yeah.
I mean maybe this is sort of a silly
question, but I'm sure it's not there.
Are there some lenders sort of in the,
in the middle,
like more optimistic pessimists to think
the upstate it's like more likely to
occur should be like maybe
are willing to let me.
Well there are people,
there are,
there's a whole continuum of
people between zero and one.
So the guys in the middle,
they really don't have any choice here.
You'd see in the,
in the two period and then the next model,
there's going to be a difference.
But now you really don't have any choice
if you're really, if you're above a,
you should buy to the maximum
loose your bolt blow away,
you should sell everything and you know,
you don't,
you don't care if you lend or not because
you're definitely going to get paid
back. So they're all
willing to lend. Okay.
But that's not going to be so let's now,
but so let's now go to the third,
the to the next model.
So that was a great question. So far
we only get two categories of people,
buyers, borrowers, sellers,
lenders. But let's now, so,
so we're going to move beyond
that in the next example.
Any questions about this one?
Okay.
So we get equilibrium
leverage and leverage has a
tremendous effect on the price.
Why does it affect the price?
Because the fact that these guys were
able to borrow so much money is what made
the price so high.
If they couldn't borrow,
that would wipe out this
point to the price. You know,
I couldn't have borrowed that so they
would have only had this much to spend.
So the price would have had to be much
lower and of course these guys wouldn't
have been able to afford all this. So
you know, as the price gets much lower,
more people would want to buy and you'd
the marginal buyer down here and there'd
be a much lower price. So this is
borrowing is what jacked up the price.
Leverage means high prices.
It seems like the most obvious thing in
the world and common sensical thing in
the world. But remember it never
got mentioned in this course,
right?
It never gets mentioned in any textbook.
The price is supposed to
be the fundamental value,
the present value of all the dividends.
Well present value of the expected
present value of all the dividends,
meaning nine is the covariance or
something where it was leveraged in that
formula, it didn't happen. Okay.
Because we didn't have the idea.
We assume that everyone could
borrow as much as they wanted to,
but here we see that they can't
borrow as much as they want to.
They're limited in how much they can
borrow. And because they're limited,
it's going to turn out.
If you make the limit less severe,
they're going to borrow more and the
price is going to be higher. You know,
so you,
you ignore leverage by saying people
can always borrow whatever they want to,
then you didn't never gets
mentioned. Uh, but okay,
but it's the heart of the matter I
think, at least in a crisis. Okay,
so let's just do one more
version of the model.
Okay.
Which is the same thing but
now with one extra period.
So what's the extra period going to do?
The extra period is we've got,
instead of two periods,
we have three periods.
So what's going to happen is the collapse,
the point to only happens with
two pieces of damn bad news.
You have to go down twice to get 0.2.
Otherwise why pays off one?
And everyone's going to begin at the
beginning there with one unit of y and one
unit of gold just as before.
And they're going to pay a,
and they could consume in the middle
or they could consume in the end.
But they have no more endowments.
All their endowments are
right at the beginning, one
unit of Y, one unit of gold.
There's no discounting. They just
care about the expected consumption,
the differences. Now it takes two
periods to see the realization.
So two pieces of bad news.
Now why is that interesting
to pieces of bad news? Well,
when I was in the crisis,
both in 98 when I thought about
this model created this model,
but it also recently is,
you know,
people start to realize
things are going wrong.
So something goes wrong and
everyone says, well, you know,
things are still okay now, but I
realize we're closer. You know,
it takes a lot of things to go wrong
for things to collapse, but you know,
each time one of them goes wrong,
you're a little closer to the collapse.
So you see what happens is that,
uh,
so I make the assumption that every agent
agents are all identical except agent
h high h means you think
you're going to get up moves.
But there are two moves at the
beginning and also in the second period.
So if you're an optimist
about the first up move,
you're also going to be an
optimist about the second up move.
Now let's suppose your h equals 0.87 say
just to pick a number which is going to
turn out to be a pivotal guy,
Mr 87 at the beginning,
the chances of going down our 13% for him,
then 13% more.
So the chance of getting a
disaster he thinks is 13% squared,
1.69% under 2% so he thinks the value of
the asset is over 98 cause with 98 per,
you know under 2% here, the rest of
the 98 must be over there somewhere.
So it's obviously his valuation has
over 98 now once he gets down to here,
he realizes the chances have
gone from 1.69% to 13% okay,
so his valuation is going to be a little
bit more than 87 because it's going to
be 87% of that and 13% of that.
So it's 87 plus a little bit.
So he's going to go down from
98 something to 87 something.
So of course when the first downstate
happens, everybody gets more pessimistic,
including Mr 87 he now
thinks that the acid value,
maybe one from 98 to 87
which is an 11 point drop.
Okay? And everybody's
going to have a drop. He,
he went from a 98 plus
two 87 plus a little bit.
So it was an 11 point drop is
what he thinks happened. Okay?
So you can see this as bad news
when you, when, when they're,
it takes two things to go wrong.
The first piece of bad news is going to,
you know,
people are going to take it as bad news.
But the interesting thing that happens
is that actually they get more uncertain.
So this is a very special, you know,
things go up, you get one for sure.
Now you've learned something.
There's no uncertainty here.
The move down created more uncertainty
than you had before. So if you look,
and not only that more disagreement,
I mean Mr Point nine and Mr [inaudible],
Mr [inaudible] and Mr Point eight neither
of them thought there was much chance
of getting down to here. Point nine
thought 1% squared. That's negligible.
Point eight thought 2% squared this 0.0
for the differences between negligible
and 0.04 still negligible practically.
So they hardly disagree here.
But once you get down to here,
they're both starting to get more
worried and they're actually deferring a
little bit more than they did before.
So that's what I think happens in
these crises. You go from, you know,
everyone knowing him for
about 25,025 things in a row
go wrong, we're in trouble.
But how many,
you know,
nobody's really thinking except the
guys at the very bottom that all of this
stuff can go wrong.
But once each thing goes wrong,
now everyone gets more and more worried
and there's more separation between what
people think. Okay? So that's
just description of the model.
So what's going to happen is the question.
Okay.
So we're almost at the end here
because you don't have to do much more
calculations.
Um,
so what will the price is be
at the beginning and down here?
And what will the leverage be at
the beginning and down here? Well,
remember our principal that the leverage
will always be worked out in this case
of heterogeneous beliefs
so that people can promise.
So there'll be no default.
The maximum promises is the most you
can make without any chance of default.
So you can see that.
I'll tell you what the prices
are there going to be that.
So if you made a two period loan into,
you know,
along loan, a lot can go
wrong. Over long loan,
you can get all the way down to 0.2,
so you're not gonna be able to borrow
very much if you make a two period loan.
If you make a one period loan, you
know, in a day, not much can go wrong.
That's why these repo markets
are so short in one day.
Practically nothing can go wrong
or hear something does go wrong,
but you can fall to 0.69 a
lot better than 0.2. Okay?
So you could borrow at the beginning 0.69.
That'll be the equilibrium promise
at the beginning will be 0.69 with no
interest. The equilibrium promise
here will be 0.2 with no interest.
The equilibrium promise there will
be one with no interest. Okay,
so, alright, so this turns out
to be the equilibrium. Why?
Notice how shocking it is.
Nobody thinks the price dropped
from 95 to 69 is justified.
That's a huge 26% drop.
Mr 87 he thought the price should go
from 98 to [inaudible] 87 that's an 11
point drop. Mr One thought it
was worth one at the beginning.
He still thinks it's worth one.
That's no drug. Mr Z H equals zero.
Thought it was worth 0.2 at the beginning
and still thinks it's worth 0.2.
That's no drop Mr. I mean, no
wonder, no matter who you pick,
I think the worst one is 0.5. Point
five thought it was worth. Um,
we have to figure it out.
25% chance of going down here,
75 up there.
So 0.75 plus a plus 0.5 is 0.8 right?
25% of 0.2 is a 0.05 so 0.75
so Mr h equals 0.5 things.
It's the expected payoff is 0.8 75%
of one of those ones and 25% of 0.2 is
another 0.05 so 0.75 and 405 is 0.8 so
he thinks down here where he said 0.5
it's now worth 0.5 and 0.5 of this,
it's 0.6 so he thought the drops would
be from 80 to 60 a 20 point drop.
That's the biggest drop anybody
could imagine 20 points.
Most people are at 11 points or
zero points or something like that.
Nobody's at a 26 point drop.
That's way bigger than anybody could
imagine is justified by the bad news and
the economy. Yet that's what
the equilibrium becomes. Okay.
From 95% to 69% so why is that?
That's the end of the story.
What happened in the drop? Well,
three things went wrong. Okay. In the Er.
So the first thing is that
87 is the marginal buyer.
So everyone above him bought
all of these optimists.
We're buying everyone else sold in London
money. Okay, now what?
I'm assuming that and it's going to
turn out to be the correct answer. Now,
how did I know 87 well, I'll
tell you, you'll see at the end.
Yeah. Question. No, just
fixing your hair. That's okay.
Okay,
so 87% eight Mr 87 is the marginal buyer.
So those guys at the top Bot, now, how
could they afford to buy so much? Well,
they're borrowing so much.
They're borrowing 0.69. Okay.
Plus they already had their 0.31.
So together they can borrow.
If they can spend 0.69 plus 0.13
that's point 82 that they're uh,
it's point 82 that they're spending
and they're only buying 87.
And so 82 or 87 is about 95.
So there's a little rounding going on.
So that's why the price is 0.95.
Now, why did it crash to 0.69?
It crashed because look what happened.
These total optimist at the beginning,
the top 13% they borrowed,
they spent all the money that they had.
There are 13% cigarettes, uh,
uh, gold. They spent the 13%,
they borrowed everything they
could to the hilt. So they old 0.6,
nine in both states.
So what happens to them here?
They spent all their gold and they all
the total value of their collateral.
They're wiped out here.
They've got nothing left.
So the most optimistic people in the
economy, they're just out of the economy.
They've all gone bankrupt.
So now we've got a smaller population
with less optimistic people.
Okay? And so these, these new optimists
are going to do the buying now. Well,
first of all, they don't think
the asset's worth as much for,
for a bunch of reasons. One is they
got bad news, so the people were left.
Don't think it's worth as much
as they did from the beginning.
Plus the most optimistic people at
the beginning aren't there either.
And then lastly,
and most importantly,
the people who are left can't borrow very
much money because the leverage at the
beginning was 0.95 or 4.26 you could
borrow 69 so you had to pay down 0.26
that's 3.6 leverage here.
The prices 0.69 you can only borrow
0.2 so you have to put 0.49 down.
The leverage is 1.4 so you went from three
and a half leverage to one and a half
leverage. The leverage collapsed.
And so these guys who are left,
okay,
they're not as optimistic. They thems
themselves cause they've got bad news.
The most optimistic people are gone and
the people who want to do the bind can't
borrow as much. So there are three
reasons that drives the price down.
The marginal buyer becomes a
much lower guy than before.
And so that's why the price is lower.
It's not just the bad news because Mr 87
or you know would never have justified
that drop.
It's because the thing has fallen
into more pessimistic hands.
So all those bankers and hedge funds who
bought all his mortgage securities at
the beginning, they've been wiped out by
now. They're way up here. They can't buy.
They're much more sober. People who are
left, who also know we've had bad news,
they're willing to pay less to begin
with them. There are fewer of, you know,
on their warm pessimistic and
they can't borrow very much.
So the price drops for all those reasons.
I think that's the essence of the crash.
Three reasons that the people going
bankrupt where the most optimistic buyers,
the second reason because the news
was bad. That's the first one.
Ruses bad optimistic buyers going up,
going out and the leverage collapsing.
Okay, so the price drops along way. It's,
I'll end with one more slide and then
sum up the last slide is his question
about the classes of people. Okay. It's,
it's a little different
now than it was before.
There are different classes of people.
Okay, so let's just think about this.
Why was the marginal buyer,
Mr 87 I mean, after all,
we just computed,
Mr 87 thinks the value of the assets.
98 not 95 he doesn't,
you know,
Mr 86 also thinks the price,
the value of the acid is 90 98 about,
so why didn't 86 by,
he was getting a good
deal at the beginning.
Why was an 86 buying when he
thinks it's worth 98 here,
Mr. Point eight six remember
is not supposed to buy.
He's going to buy the next time.
See you Mr 86 there's just,
he's the cautious optimist.
Okay.
Mr 86 there just below 87 he's
going to buy after the crash,
but he's not buying now. So why is it
that he's not buying it at the beginning?
Well, so this is the only subtlety,
but you answered to your question,
Mr 86 says to himself, you
know, I can make a profit.
I think it's worth 98 and I only have to
pay 95 that's like a 3% expected return
and I'm risk neutral. So that's
great. You know, if I'm right,
it goes from 95 to a hundred I
can get 5% on the other hand,
maybe I should wait for the crash.
The crash comes, the thing is worth,
I don't have to pay 69 I can
get 40% return, you know,
31 over 69 whatever that is,
I can get a 40% return. Um,
if there's a a crash,
wouldn't that be,
that's much better than
my 5% if I'm right.
So it looks so that guy is waiting to,
to make money in the crash.
So of course by waiting and buying in
the crash, he's helping to reduce the,
the terrible calamity cause he's a buyer.
If we just had more people like that,
I think that is Warren Buffet.
Okay.
I call them the cautious optimist all
the way down to Mr. Point seven for Mr.
Point seven five for example.
Also think the things,
the acid is worth more than 0.95 at the
beginning, but he doesn't buy either.
So all these people,
the cautious optimist,
they're holding out for the crash and the
crash would be much worse without them,
but they don't eliminate the crash
because they're not enough of them.
So here are the three classes of
people you were thinking about.
They're not quite as optimistic.
They still think it's a good buy,
but they decide not to buy,
waiting for the crash.
Now how did I know that it would stop at
87 and [inaudible] 74 how did they get
all those numbers? Well, I don't have time
to derive them. Those are the equations,
but I can explain it very simply.
You see thinking you're going to take
advantage of the crash means it must have
a high h. You think of things, go here,
they're still going to end up okay.
That's why you think there's
a big profit opportunity.
But if your age is too high,
you don't think you're ever
going to get to the crash.
So you've only got this small intermediate
group of people, the Warren Buffet,
like people who are optimistic enough
to think that we're going to pull out of
our depression.
You know,
pull out of the crash and still there's
a profit opportunity and yet think that
the crash is likely enough
so that they'll wait for it.
People who think they'll make a bigger
profit higher h once the crash starts,
well they don't even think the
crash is going to happen. Okay.
So I've made a big assumption
that if you start with, you know,
the people with high h has always had
high ages. Okay. But I think that's life.
I think that's not a bad assumption.
I every hedge fund guy I've ever talked
to who thought that this was a low
probability event also thought we are
going to come out of it and things
wouldn't be that bad. Okay. So I'm not
saying that these people don't learn.
Everybody learns when they see
the first piece of bad news.
They're more pessimistic. You'd
go from, from uh, you know, 1.6,
9% to 13%. So it's not like people
are learning, they are learning.
But relative to the rest of the
population, if you started optimistic,
you stay optimistic.
And that's why there's only a small group
of Warren Buffet's who could save the
situation.
All right?
So that's my model of the leverage
cycle of what happens. You know,
three bad things happen,
bad news can't do anything about that.
The leverage buyers get crushed,
go out of business and,
and leverage collapses. So if you,
and when the prices are really low,
the whole economy is suffering
tremendously and innocent
people who had nothing
to do with all these markets, the
price of everything, every acid is low.
So they can't borrow, they can't
get loans. Margins are so tough.
They're small businesses. They can't
borrow there. Totally crushed down here.
So how would we save the economy?
We'd undo the three things that happen.
We'd have to,
we can't undo the bad news,
but the three things that
happened were uncertainty went up.
It wasn't just bad news.
It was scary. Bad News.
So this ans this gap between one and
0.2 is much bigger than that gap.
That's why the leverage went down.
Volatility went up.
So you have to contain the bad
news. Okay? That would help.
You have to contain the bad news. That's
a, so you can't eliminate the bad news,
but you can contain the volatility
of the bad news. Secondly,
you have to increase the leverage.
And thirdly,
you have to make up for the people
who've gotten destroyed. You know, the,
the buying power has gone
somehow the government has
to replace that temporarily.
So those are the three things
we should be doing now.
And in the long run we should never
have let leverage gets so high up here.
That's what made the
price so high up here.
And that's why everyone got wiped out
down here cause they were borrowing so
much.
We should never have let that happen.
So if we regulate the economy
not to let leverage get so high,
we won't have such a cry crash.
But if we do have a crash,
the way to deal with it is to undo
the three things that went wrong.
That's the sort of story that
I've been telling you. Yes.
Okay. So what are they?
That's a wonderful question.
And of course I've been asked that before,
so let me put it in
several different ways.
Let's take the most hyper
critical way. Um, some people,
so I presented this theory, remember
starting in 2000, so way before the crash.
And so people would say then,
oh, very nice, very cute.
But you know, first of all,
there's not going to be a crash.
And secondly,
how could we ever know what the
right amount of leverage is?
It's an impossible pie in the sky
goal to regulate leverage. Okay,
well you see, that's why. So I say,
that's why I say it's difficult.
I agree. But we've already faced this
problem. We regulate the interest rate.
How does the Fed know that the
interest rates too low or too high?
What the Fed does is it monitors a
bunch of stuff and realizes, you know,
the economies overheat, things
are changing. Suddenly price,
suddenly output is going way up
and inflation is starting to go up.
Then the Fed raises the interest rate
or maybe people are being thrown out of
work. Then the Fed lowers the interest
rate. So something changes in the economy.
They don't know. So precisely you know
what to do, but something's changed.
That gives them a clue about
which way to move interest rates.
And over the course of 80 years of, I
guess since the depression, you know,
since those created over
70 or 80 years since then,
they've gotten better and better at, at,
at regulating the interest rate. Okay.
So I put this picture up for a reason.
Uh,
last class, you remember
the reason, the picture,
which I'm going to get to now I'm
of the history of leverage. Okay?
So here's the history of leverage.
The purple in the housing market,
and then the, uh, blue is the history
of leverage. You know, the, the,
it's the loan to value
basically, or the, you know,
I've put money down starting
from the top and going down.
So it's really from the bottom,
it's loan to value.
So I've got the history of loan to value
in the securities market and in the
mortgage market.
Now,
I think that the Fed should be monitoring
this and not only should be monitoring,
it should be making it as public
as the interest rates are.
So how come I had to present Ellington's
data on observations it made in the
market because Ellington seems to have
been the only company in the country that
kept this data.
Nobody else seemed to recognize how
important it was and we kept it so the Fed
doesn't have this, this, these
numbers going back. If it did,
it would have seen that leverage had
suddenly jumped up here and that leverage
was much higher than it was before.
And it would see if it monitored
leverage in the housing market.
That leverage was skyrocketing. I
mean, of course everybody knew this,
they just didn't think it was an
important thing to pay attention to.
But if they were paying attention
to it and keeping those numbers,
we had to do this at Ellington
by going house, by house,
through every house looking at what the
leverage was and taking the average.
If they had done that, I mean they could
have done that easily. And if they were,
if they did do that and if there were
publishing it and everyone in the every
economist was aware of it, I think
things would have been very different.
They would've said, you know, we ought
to, to, to tighten leverage, you know,
exactly how much should we tighten it.
While they would have said,
I don't know exactly,
but we would have forced banks not to
allow loans with 3% down, you know,
shouldn't be 10% or 15% or 8%.
It's a little hard to say what
exactly the right number is,
but we would have picked a number higher
than 3% and we would have avoided a
huge problem. Um, and you know,
in later years we'll get better
and better at picking that number.
So I'm trying to answer your question.
Um,
so in the securities market,
another thing you could do,
another trick you could
do is you could say,
we'll pass a rule that says you can't
hear leverage is going down, right?
They're asking for more and more margins.
You could pass a rule that
says you can't double your,
your margins,
you know,
from 10% to 20% or 20 to 40.
You can't double them in
under four months. Say,
so that would on average
across some security class,
you can't double them in
less than four months.
Well or less than six months.
So that would have kept leverage
from collapsing so fast.
And then lenders knowing that when
the crisis was starting, you know,
they're making one day loans,
they always think of what's a one day
loan and things start to look dicey.
I'll just demand a huge amount of leverage
the next day I'll get my money back
tomorrow and then the day after tomorrow,
I'm not going to make the same loan.
I'll ask for a lot more margin. So I'm
saying, suppose you tell them an advance,
you have to keep making the same
loan and you can't double the margin,
you can increase it. But if you have to
take at least six months to double it,
well they'll know in advance that they're
not going to be able to react very
quickly to problems. And so on advanced
they'll ask for more margin down.
So you know,
they won't have to double to get to a
safe level when something starts happening
because they'll already be safer.
So that's a way of not having to actually
know what the right number is by just
slowing down their response and
relying them to anticipate, you know,
how bad things might be in the already
starting to respond to the beginning.
Okay. So I'm not saying I've got
exactly the right formula, but you see,
I think if you think about
it and start to work on this,
and most importantly you
make these numbers public,
you're going to change the way
everybody, you know, other people will,
rules will develop.
Yeah.
Are they going to set one leverage rate?
Which or is it going to
be like for each class?
Yes. Each class of security
will have a different leverage.
Okay. So, so when you say classic
security, like what do you,
I mean like, uh, you know, uh,
well the government already makes a lot
of loans to Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac,
but Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac will have
to ask for at least 20% down. You know,
prime securities will
have prime mortgages,
will have to have at least
this much amount of money down.
So you're on the housing market,
you'll have to have a certain
amount of money down on treasuries.
You can have a very high leverage
on mortgage and mortgages,
plain simple mortgages. You can have
not quite as quite as high a leverage,
but you know, some, uh, you
know, uh, pretty high leverage
on mortgage derivatives,
which are much more complicated.
The leverage has to be much less.
So you might say, you know,
there'll be some rule that says, um,
so anyway,
those are the kinds of classes that I
have in mind and we have to work out
exactly how the, uh, you know,
how they're going to be regulated.
So it's a little bit comp. So let me
answer your question two parts. Yes.
It has to depend on the
kind of security and B,
even trying to answer your question,
I'm revealing that is not so obvious
exactly what the formula is and how to do
it, but this has to be worked out. Yup.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah. Well I think, yes, yes.
I think that's the whole point of the
crisis that the uh, the things, uh,
feedback on each other.
The feedback is the most important thing.
So in the crisis, uh, let's do take
any one of these, when the price went,
when leverage starts to go down,
that makes the prices start to go down.
But when the prices start to go down,
people get more worried that things
are going to go down further. I mean,
they have good reason to worry and
so the leverage goes down more,
which makes the prices go down more.
And so they feed back on each other.
So definitely there it's, it's a
bad, it's a spiral of one thing, uh,
affecting the other. And of course
the more the prices are going down,
the more the optimist are losing money.
And so your most,
your best buyers are getting wiped
out. And that's a third thing. That's,
those three things are always
feeding back on each other.
Okay.
No, because the model was
totally rational. Every
person did expect all this.
Everyone anticipated
perfectly what would happen.
So there's no Lucas and the Lucas
Critique is, you know, if you,
people will realize they're
in a different, uh, you know,
people should realize the environment
they're in. But here in this,
in this environment,
everybody up here understood from the
very beginning that the prices were going
to go down to 0.6, nine, they
realized that there was going
to be this, uh, this, uh,
acceleration of problems.
And so they all anticipated but still
they wanted to buy because they didn't
think they were going to get down there.
They thought they were going to go
up here. So remember my, uh, my, uh,
I don't know if I have it in this slide,
but one of my most amazing
pictures was this one of a,
uh,
was the, what happened to the market
open. So what happened to the market here,
which I think I've showed you
as time. I mean, know I did,
but I'll just show it to you again.
Now with this new perspective,
you can look at it, uh, presents.
Yeah.
So this is a, this is Jerusalem.
I gave this talk in Jerusalem.
Yeah.
Okay.
Second
Talk.
Okay.
So you remember this picture?
Hope it wasn't this lie. This. Yes,
it was he earth here. I'll get,
remember what happened in the world.
It was shocking how bad
and how fast it was.
So in 2007 beginning of 2007 Oh,
that's right.
We're not far from the beginning
of 2007 that's three years ago.
People were expecting 40%
losses for these lower tronches.
Okay, so how could you get
such an astronomical loss?
You know what was happening?
They were already anticipating
this spiral. You know,
if you looked at just what housing
prices were there and you say, okay,
30% guys being thrown out,
you know,
and housing prices are down 4% that's
hardly any loss at all because if you get
96% back on the house and you have a few
expenses and only 30% are defaulting,
first of all, they probably, you know,
there was hardly anybody to faulting.
Remember that curves we show we're
through almost any losses and no one going
delinquent yet.
So what?
They already anticipated that there were
going to be lots of people thrown out
of their houses and when they
got thrown out of their houses,
the housing prices were going to collapse.
So this market was collapsing already
because people were anticipating all the,
you know, a lot of the feedbacks and
stuff that we're going to happen later.
They didn't just extrapolate
the number of the faults.
They also had to extrapolate the
housing prices and stuff going down.
And so in this model,
everybody is doing that complicated
extrapolation and they're getting it,
uh,
know they're doing this complicated
extrapolation and they're figuring it all
out.
But even so,
they still want to put themselves in
the cycle because they still think they
have a profit opportunity.
They can't stop themselves for investing.
That's why you need regulation.
It's like a prisoner's dilemma.
Everybody knows what the danger is.
They still want to do it and the
only way to stop them from doing it,
you can't lecture them about,
you know, irrational exuberance.
They know what's going to happen
and they still want to do it.
They don't think that's going to happen.
They know what could happen and
they still want to do it now.
I think in reality Schiller's got
something to Oh is partly right.
I think that people didn't really
realize how bad it could have gotten.
My own hedge fund lost money,
you know,
we didn't anticipate how bad it was
because there's so many things went wrong.
We just underestimated all the feedbacks.
So there,
there is the spiral and they were
just more things going wrong than we
anticipated. So I wouldn't stick
a hundred percent of my story.
I think there's something
to what Schiller says,
but I wouldn't definitely stick to 100%
of his story of it being all irrational
exuberance.
Okay.
Any other questions now that
we have five minutes for?
Um, so I'm willing to keep
going for it. It's all,
it's just pause for any more questions
on this story of the crisis or anything
else about the crisis you want to ask or,
Yup.
Um, well that's a good
question. So I, I, I'm,
I talked to them now all the time,
so they, whereas I never did before.
So our meeting Dudley, uh, tomorrow,
he's the head of the New York Fed.
Um,
so I go there quite frequently,
like once a month now. And
it's, I'm on some panels,
there are other academics going to,
so, you know, I didn't do that before.
So clearly they're paying attention to it.
I think that a lot of,
there are other people saying
that leverages important.
Soros being a famous hedge
fund person who says it.
Uh, there are other people saying
that you should reduce principal.
Remember I said that the way to solve
the housing foreclosure problems reducing
principal, they're now holding hearings
in Congress. Uh, I suppose, uh, you know,
I could've gone Tuesday to testify,
but I have already testified,
but they're having another
other hearings now.
I didn't go because I
was teaching, but on, um,
but there are a lot of people who went
and a lot of people said we should reduce
principal.
And a year ago when I was saying that,
hardly anyone else was saying it,
although there were, there were others.
But very few, uh, my
people at my hedge fund,
we all pretty much a cid CII on this and
some other hedge funds were saying that.
But now I think there's a
growing consensus that we
have to reduce principal.
What does that do?
It makes the loan smaller relative to
the value of the house. In other words,
it reduces the leverage
of, of of homeowners. Okay.
So we have to get back to uh,
uh, credible level of leverage.
So,
um,
the bad news is that although they're
very receptive and although they're
listening carefully and they
keep inviting me to speak,
I don't see much signs that
they're doing anything.
And the one thing that they should have
done by now is collected all this data.
So they should have gone to all the big
lenders and said the Fed should have and
said,
this is the margins we're charging on
all our different securities and heres a,
you know,
here they are.
And then the Fed would be able to monitor
how much they were going up and down.
Now a bunch of these lenders themselves
have also become excited about what I'm
doing and they're starting for publish
reports about it. So one, Credit Suisse,
for example, they, they,
their research department now thinks that
a better measure of money is not just
m one and m two and all that stuff.
But how many loans leverage loans are
made in the repo market and they add that
to the money supply and they think
that gives a much better picture of the
economy.
So it's all sort of based on these ideas.
And I think I got them interested in it
or was one of the people that got them
interested in it,
but they aren't going to publish their
leverage numbers unless everybody else
does because why should they give away
private information? Why should they say,
you know,
we're lending Ellington on slightly more,
less generous or more generous terms.
Then we're lending to some other guy.
One of the two of us is going to feel
bad about it and so they're not going to
do that.
And so the government is the only one
that can get the information out of them
and the government shouldn't say who
are they lending to? Person by person.
They should give the average number.
This is the average margin
they're charging people.
The average number of the banks
in general are charging people.
Then you won't be able to re, you won't
be revealing any private information,
giving away any secrets.
So that's the worst news that
they're not collecting the data yet.
And it's shocking to me.
So I've had many times,
so I'm gonna yell at Dudley
about that again Friday,
but I've done it before so
hopefully they're going to do that.
They say they're going to do that.
So I believe they'll do that.
And I believe that once
they have all these numbers,
they're going to start to
think differently. Um, so
there are all these, um, the,
there's all these initiatives in Congress
and in the Fed and in the treasury to
try and monitor leverage
and try to regulate it. But,
but every time they get down
to actually doing something,
they ask questions like you did,
what exactly should the rule be?
And they seem paralyzed by not being
able to figure out the exact rule.
But I don't,
I think that's an unnecessary paralysis
because we don't have to have the final
rule to start doing stuff.
Yes.
The Fed,
the Fed has the power to do it.
The Fed already regulates
margins on stocks, right?
They set the margin of 50% or something,
and so they could change that and
they have changed that in the past,
so they should change.
So the Fed has the authority to do that.
The Fed did that after nine 11
and called everybody up and said,
right after nine 11 and said,
you cannot change your margins.
And nobody changed their margins.
I mean,
if ever there was a day when people
were nervous and wanted to have a higher
margin, it was on nine 12.
Nobody changed their margins.
So they've done it before.
Um, but, but you know,
that's a pretty extreme day.